[VIOLIN MUSIC]
[SPEAKING ROMANIAN]
I, uh--
You don't speak Romanian?
[VIOLIN PLAYING]
WOMAN: You don't like?
- No.
It's lovely.
[LAUGHS] There's this guy
that lives across the street,
and he's always
looking over here.
Looking over here how?
WOMAN: Every time
I look over there,
he's just staring right at me.
[WIND HOWLING]
[SWITCH CLICKS]
MAN: Hello, darling.
Any reason in particular
you're standing in the dark?
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
Do you feel like
coming in for a drink?
Yeah.
Have you noticed anyone
watching you in your apartment?
No.
This guy has been watching
us since we moved in.
Maybe he's staring at the
woman who's staring at him.
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
[CHAIR CREAKS]
[EXHALES]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
WOMAN: What's happening?
[SIREN WAILS]
MAN (VOICEOVER):
They found a woman
murdered in her apartment.
They're saying the woman
had her head cut off.
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
The man at the movie
theater followed me
into the supermarket.
Followed you?
[CHAIR CREAKS]
WOMAN (VOICEOVER): [GASPS]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
That's him.
[DOOR CRANKING]
WOMAN (VOICEOVER): I
need to know for myself
that he's been following me.
[CHAIR CREAKS]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
MAN (VOICEOVER): Sometimes
I just look at people.
MAN: Just tell me what
you want me to do.
I want you to believe me!
MAN (VOICEOVER): Sure,
they can seen me.
MAN: [SCREAMS]
I heard screaming
from in here.
OK?
- Did you?
Just open the door, please!
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
MAN (VOICEOVER):
Dreaming of [INAUDIBLE]
pretty girl looking back at me.
[GASPS]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
But no one has
really noticed before.
[PANTING]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
[SOMBER MUSIC]